foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
happy happy happy happy tuesday
welcome to d tony michael's podcast
where we do the [ __ ] list roundup round
up all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends
of the day
holy [ __ ]
share a lot of news i forgot yesterday
i forgot to talk about how tucker
carlson beats off the m m's
i'm not really sure exactly how this
works with him
oops i'm not sure exactly i'm still
getting used to this this new format
that we got going you guys like the new
format we have going the two hours every
single day we do the [ __ ] list roundup
and then we do the podcast stuff you
guys like that gabe was here yesterday
now i don't i don't think he's going to
be able to join us today all the gabe
fans out there you know i really
apologize for that we'll make sure we'll
make sure that we get him on uh
wednesday or thursday but it looks like
we're gonna have a guest on possibly
tomorrow so
stay tuned for that we gotta uh i think
we're recording a guest interview with
trivia and everything to either air
wednesday or thursday
um i i've been messaging michael popock
you guys might know michael popock from
legal af
he he's gonna owe us a a pop-in we've
got a lot of questions from some legal
stuff
um of course they do their new show on
weekdays uh wednesday and then they do
their weekend show
hopefully we'll have him pop in soon
then we'll do bonehead of the week on
friday second hour of the tony michaels
podcast the greatest part now is we're
on youtube look at all these comments
coming in holy moly
audio is low
well let's turn it up a bit
let's turn it up a bit
so i'm good huh
is it good is the is the sound good
everybody can everyone here everyone's
here mj is here
she said what's up [ __ ] army
we kind of coined that yesterday i guess
robin says good morning good morning
robin uh
who else we got in here we got yoda in
here uh we've got uh
we just uh here's kaelin everyone's
joining us here
midas lisa says oh good pop yeah
hopefully we'll get po-pok on i've been
trying to strong-arm in the last couple
weeks our schedules is not lined up
worth a [ __ ]
but that's how it works you know on live
on live shows you know you don't get the
opportunity to record when it's
convenient you just gotta go with it you
just gotta go with it
thanks everyone for uh oh here's eugene
eugene
how are you this morning good morning
doing all the good mornings and the high
fives
so again we're doing two hours a day
every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central so we won't be
doing the wednesday afternoon show now
that we're doing two hours every single
day but the good news is is that it's on
youtube every single [ __ ] day live
youtube twitter twitch wherever you'd
like to watch it now most people are
preparing the youtube channel
um
i guess i guess twitch is more of the
gamey thing you know we were on twitch
for a while go follow me on twitch don't
don't discount it over there i get a lot
of people that like to watch the videos
over there but we're also on twitter
who's out there on twitter see the
problem with the twitter watching on
twitter is i don't actually we don't we
don't actually get to pull in
uh the the comments from the broadcast
so if you're watching over on twitter
thank you for watching but if you'd like
to comment you know click on that
youtube link that i have on the uh
the post there and then you can come
over and you can just you can start to
you start yoda says twitch is laggy yeah
twitch
people complain that it glitches a
little bit youtube doesn't glitch as
much i guess i i don't know what the
difference is you got me i [ __ ] i
don't know i just push the [ __ ]
buttons and go live i know i twitch i
select the ones my youtube twitch
twitter go live
and here i am right in front of you
every single weekday two hours a day
every single
every single weekday
you guys like that format pretty cool
huh yeah that robin said hits the thumbs
up yeah oh yeah you're good reminding me
robin do the youtube thing whatever it
is that you're supposed to do you know
whatever i'm supposed to say hit the
like button subscribe all that kind of
you know
you know i do the thought whatever it is
that these youtubers do to get you to to
interact do that
uh
hopefully we'll have some trolls come in
today everyone likes having the uh the
trolls in the comments section in the
live chat i like the trolls in the live
chat i like i like having hate watchers
we have hate watchers here every single
day i love it i love the hate watchers
so there's a lot of stuff in the news uh
you know there's
neil young the fda
kate mckinnon
laura ingram
clowns herself apparently rupert murdoch
is trending i'm not sure why chuck todd
uh and fake news are trending i don't i
don't know if that's if that has
anything to do with each other but we'll
find out today
on the [ __ ] list roundup so uh you know
what we should probably do is just go
ahead and just get right into the [ __ ]
list roundup
and we'll talk about i want to go back
from the weekend because uh you guys
heard the you seen the video of tucker
carlson
uh cucking on the um on the m m's
[Laughter]
tucker carlson is an m m cuck let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back thanks for
thanks for hanging in with us uh we're
gonna start the [ __ ] list roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
attorney trends that's probably gonna be
the show today because we just have so
[ __ ] much of this stuff
um out there today then i want to rail
on some [ __ ] that i forgot over the
weekend the main thing is
i wanted to talk about yesterday [ __ ]
forgot about it yeah mj
alpha cut carlson there you go
perfect hashtag get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
trending robin says let's [ __ ] go
let's do this
um mj says
she loves the [ __ ] army yes [ __ ] them
all right so so you guys may have heard
that tucker carlson has a thing for the
green eminem i don't know if you heard
this or not um apparently
he he really gets off on the green
eminem um and he's really [ __ ] upset
now that he can't have his m m porn i
don't know if this is like he separates
out the green m m's because he watches
the [ __ ] cartoon and sees that that
the eminent has sexy shoes on or
something so i don't know if he's like
he's like pulling out the green m m's
and putting them in its own bowl and
jerking off on the ball i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing
but he's really [ __ ] upset that the
green eminem is gonna have tennis shoes
on instead of high heels now and it's
just not as sexy the ass of the m m the
ass of the m m just is not gonna look
the same what is [ __ ] with these
people what in the actual [ __ ] are these
people doing let's let's see if we can
find this [ __ ] clip of carlson and
the eminence
it's just absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
that we even have to [ __ ] do this i
can't even believe that i have to
[ __ ] search a goddamn video of tucker
carlson
cucking on the [ __ ] green m m it's
just i i can't even
it's it's
it's [ __ ] beyond parody
oh
tucker [ __ ] carlson you gotta be
kidding me okay let's let's go to this
thing and see see what we got here
let's uh let's make this bigger i
definitely want to clown this
[ __ ] properly
uh right wing cope here says tucker
carlson is outraged that m m's don't
make him horny enough anymore
oh my god
oh this [ __ ] guy how in the [ __ ]
oh
i don't even know how we made it this
far in humanity really honestly to the
point to where tucker carlson has a
[ __ ] show that millions of people
watch every goddamn day they believe
every [ __ ] stupid thing this idiot
says
and this dumb [ __ ] is on his show
talking about how the ass of the eminem
just isn't good enough for him anymore
because they drew the eminem with tennis
shoes on instead of [ __ ] high heels
and the liberals the liberals are gonna
take sex out of everything what the [ __ ]
are you talking about this is the
dumbest [ __ ] thing i've ever heard of
in my life
liberals liberals are the ones that
don't want porno liberals are the ones
that don't want things to be sexy
liberals are the ones that don't want to
show [ __ ] skin and nudity get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] have been bitching and
moaning and complaining the last [ __ ]
half century
about [ __ ] porno and you got josh
hawley bitching up porno's the biggest
[ __ ] thing ever there's white dudes
jacking off and it's making white dudes
look [ __ ] fragile and weak
because they play video games and jack
off all day
you [ __ ] have been obsessed
with people's sexuality for for a whole
[ __ ] half century
no one else gives a [ __ ] about someone's
sexuality if you if you were an eminem
sexual
carlson it's okay we're not gonna
[ __ ] judge you man
if you if the m m's make you [ __ ]
horny fine whatever everyone's got their
[ __ ] kink
everybody
we're not gonna judge you
but when you go on your tv show and
you're saying stupid [ __ ] like oh
liberals trying to cancel m m's because
i want them sexy because i gotta have
some
candy porn or some [ __ ] i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about let's
listen to this [ __ ] idiot
here we go
the other big change is that the brown
eminem has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block i love the i
love the [ __ ] word transition there
too
right
like he's really this is this [ __ ]
matt walsh
matt walsh alpha cuck [ __ ] where they're
[ __ ] pissed off about trans women
because they just might go in a bar and
pick up on an m m and that m m's wearing
high heels now god damn it but what what
happens when i get that eminem home and
it transitions into tennis shoes what
the [ __ ] then huh this is this [ __ ]
fragile white male [ __ ] scared
women having a penis that they like and
they think is gorgeous and then all of a
sudden oh my god it might have been a
man they're they [ __ ] can't handle it
they are [ __ ] weak and they're
[ __ ]
it's just ridiculous this is i can't
even believe that i gotta have this
candy and sexy shoes is highly offensive
what the f that's the [ __ ]
i didn't make that up that's not [ __ ]
edited that's what they had on the
screen [ __ ] heels
also less sexy that's progress m ms will
not be satisfied until every last
cartoon character is deeply unappealing
and totally androgynous until the moment
you wouldn't want to have a drink with
any one of them what the [ __ ] are you
talking about dude having a drink with
an eminem
who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
plans a date like is there like an
eminem dating app where you swipe right
or swipe whatever it is swipe right
swipe left
i don't know maybe you got sticky
[ __ ] fingers from the candy or
something else tucker carlson
what the what the hell is what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] this video's got four and a
half four almost four and a half million
views by the way let me show you the
let's let's remove the banner at the
bottom
see this guy's got four and
4.2 million views
of this [ __ ] cucking
on [ __ ] m ms
what is wrong with this [ __ ]
jesus christ dude you got one of the
biggest audiences in the goddamn country
you can't [ __ ] find more [ __ ] to talk
about than how you want to beat off to
eminem's jesus christ when you're
totally turned off
we've achieved equity they've won
the other big change is that the brown
eminem has quote transition
oh my god
so it's the brown one that he's
concerned about not the green one i
thought it was the green one
i swore it was the green one
that was the you know i had the the
female him and i don't know i don't know
i i wasn't watching him and in porn
i i don't go you know
watch m m porn
like
most most [ __ ] human beings watch
other human beings and porn not [ __ ]
m m's what is this guy doing what the
hell is over on reddit you guys ever
been on reddit you know these [ __ ]
alpha cucks over there running around on
reddit and these other [ __ ] platforms
what are they doing over there there's
got to be some kind of i don't know
oh tucker carlson you're a
sick sick individual let's see what else
is in this thread here let's get this
thread uh because i i'm not done
i'm not done with this [ __ ] yet
let's see
hang on
there we go okay what else is in this
thread this tucker
carlson m m's
let's see what else we got here
what's brooklyn dad defiancy tucker
carlson wants people to think democrats
are coming for your sexy m m's but
really it's just tucker who's coming for
them
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh my god can you imagine this guy
standing in his [ __ ] closet
trying to hide from trying to hide from
his wife
um with his with his bowl of m m's jesus
christ um looks like chip franklin had a
video here let's watch chip's video
maybe he liked the sexy boots tucker
carlson needs a hobby the green eminem
you will notice is no longer he's got
hobbies tucker's upset at m m's for
making the sexy m m's less
sexy dude get your pants back on it's
candy every last cartoon character is
deeply unappealing i was on the road for
14 years and not once did i ever think
of an m m
maybe the occasional peppermint patty
but that was before i was married this
is the whole subject of republican
attack on democrats and i guess it makes
sense i think peppermint patties are
much sexier than folks
also less sexy another symbol of
liberals attacks on a murder remember
that when they come for you our broken
health care system failing
infrastructure outside attacks on our
democracy now for fox news it's trans
athletes the war on christmas colin
kaepernick and now the culture war
tucker carlson can't get a woody because
his m ms won't wear a thong maybe he
likes the sexy boots sexy thing america
has systemic problems but they're not m
m's they're goobers
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] tucker carlson
you are a dumb [ __ ]
now now what's funny is that he's gonna
you know he did the whole eminem thing
and then yesterday you guys seen that uh
the president
called
call i'm gonna say but it's peter
douchey right douchey and then peter
douchey and then his name douchey
he leans into the mic the president
leans in the mic goes that stupid son of
a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean he didn't even [ __ ] he didn't
he didn't hold his hand over the mic he
didn't [ __ ] move his head he didn't
really even try to whisper it under his
breath
biden just leans into that [ __ ] mic
and says that stupid son what a stupid
son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] douchey what a dumb [ __ ]
we'll get to that oh we're get we're
gonna get to that [ __ ] story don't
worry about that you know we're gonna
report that here on the tony michaels
podcast during the [ __ ] let's round up
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends um let's see uh
here here's uh recount let's see grant
has if i didn't know that
that fox is just entertainment i might
wrongly believe that tucker carlson is
actually turned on by eminem's he is
he's [ __ ] said it he [ __ ] said it
100 percent of tucker's regular viewers
now believe he is
has an eminem fetish why would he do
this to himself why would he out himself
as an eminem sexual right
on fox news a candysexual is it a
candysexual
you know like melts in your mouth not in
your hand i don't know i don't know i'm
just [ __ ] i'm snowballing here
is it a candysexual is that what we're
calling it
but recount has a video here of whoopi
goldberg from the view the views whoopi
goldberg max tucker carlson for for rant
about brown eminem becoming less sexy as
he says company is making customers
totally turned off by eminem's
transformations what the f totally
turned what no
no one cares what shoes they wear they
taste the same
like it doesn't taste different because
it's less sexy are the cartoons less
sexy i don't know jesus christ let's
listen to whoopi [ __ ] whip his ass
tucker carlson yeah has found a new
target for his outrage he is declaring
war
on the makeover that eminem is giving
its candy mascots
take a look that the brown eminem has
quote transitioned from high stilletta i
love how he's dead serious just
rewatching this every time like he's
[ __ ] dead serious about this candy
not being [ __ ] sexy enough for him to
beat off to those two lower block heels
also less sexy that's progress
m ms will not be satisfied until every
last i love how progress like they're so
[ __ ] far down the rabbit hole that
progress is a bad word to them like it's
an evil word progress like no we want to
regress
progress is not good like go look up the
[ __ ] definition of the word what in
the [ __ ] is wrong with you people people
have lost your goddamn [ __ ] minds
jesus christ
this is [ __ ] ridiculous that they
think he says pro listen listen let me
back it up just a minute
yep yep sex you can't listen also less
sexy less sex that's probably progress
meaning he's mocking it saying it's bad
progress bad
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
caleb makes a good point here tucker's
also trending because he's a pro-russian
invading
ukraine stance yeah he's pro-russia he
wants he loves putin he wants to kiss
putin's ass
so here we have this [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
yelling and screaming about how m m's
don't make him horny anymore
and he also has the stance that
we should invade ukraine and
give putin his [ __ ]
i mean he wants putin to win here
he's rooting for putin
tucker carlson is not only beating off
the [ __ ] m m's he's rooting for putin
what does that tell you about fox news
and where we're at in this country with
republicans let's continue m ms will not
be satisfied until every last cartoon
character is deeply unappealing and
totally androgynous until the moment you
wouldn't want to have a drink with any
one of them that's the goal when you're
totally turned off
we've achieved equity they've won
i i can't even i mean
he makes me
upset about that
but there are others who think that's
one of the best parts here robin says
he's also doesn't mind allowing the
american people and he is a putin yeah
that's right he he he is a putin lover
he's a [ __ ] putin lover
he is a [ __ ] putin lover but what's
funny here is that tucker carlson is
going on fox news cucking on these
[ __ ] m m's
and uh
i'm sure all the women around the
country are just flattered by this that
he that [ __ ] m m's don't make him
horny anymore i'm sure i'm sure all the
women who think that's just you know so
attractive
and i'm sure all the men that follow
suit that burn their bags of m m's
you've seen this with the carhartt thing
where carhartt said yeah you're gonna
have to get vaccinated to work in our
[ __ ] facilities either it's our
stores or our factories or our
distribution plants and the reason why
is because we can't have our employees
sick and everyone started burning their
car heart [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] so you gonna are you gonna
burn m m's now you're not gonna beat off
the m ninja what are you gonna move the
skittles taste the rainbow well that
ain't gonna work is it is it there alpha
cuck i think this campaign is trying too
hard to be work
i don't understand
it just it's it's mind-boggling [ __ ]
mind-boggling that we're even here that
we even have to be here
in this [ __ ] timeline like literally
someone from home office
unplug the [ __ ] national timeline and
plug that [ __ ] back in we need a
[ __ ] reset
bad we need to reset really [ __ ] bad
it's horrible
it's time we reset the [ __ ] national
timeline this [ __ ] is getting crazy
we seen it with um um
with the [ __ ] anti-vaxx rally thing
they had this weekend and stupid [ __ ] oh
what does scary larry say about eminence
we gotta
what exactly does tucker carlson do with
m m's when no one's looking i i don't
want to know
oh
there's got to be a video out there
right is it you know
everyone's made famous with the sex tape
right
so maybe maybe tucker is made famous
with the m m tape right but maybe we got
it maybe we need to find the m m tape
uh the carlson m m tape all right let's
go to trendy trends and tweety tweets
we're gonna get i promise we'll get to
the douchey thing that does
do she is a stupid son of a [ __ ] we'll
get to that now neil young is trending
because neil young is telling spotify
take my [ __ ] music off your platform
it's either me or joe rogan spotify he's
giving them an ultimatum um and it
sounds like he's gonna try to get other
artists to come along with him and i'm
not sure if all that's gonna work but uh
neil young is definitely making his his
feelings about spotify uh broadcasting
joe rogan known and the reason why is
because of the false information about
vaccines
it's just complete [ __ ] utter lies
utter [ __ ] lies people in this
country who are vaccinated are not dying
from the coronavirus they're not
are they contracting coronavirus sure
absolutely we knew that there was going
to be breakthrough and we told you dumb
[ __ ] long ago last year when
you had the chance to get your vaccine
if you don't get vaccinated the [ __ ]
variants are run around this country
ramp up and people will get sick
and the unvaccinated will be
hospitalized and die i think i read 57
57 was the count in los angeles county
alone is how many people died from
coronavirus this [ __ ] is not over
but the thing is is it's it the
hospitalizations and the deaths
if you're vaccinated and boosted
it it's it's pretty much it's pretty
you're in a very very very good position
that the date is showing yes you can
still get sick you can still get
symptoms
but that doesn't mean that that's the
point is that you you will receive some
symptoms you might even feel like hell
for a week or two
but not dying and needing to be
hospitalized
the hospitals don't want to treat
coronavirus anymore you stupid [ __ ]
they don't want to do it and the crazy
part is is these [ __ ] idiots just
months ago were all for the [ __ ] um
the the mona gold bomb whatever the [ __ ]
it is the regeneron and the rindisovir
they were all for those those are the
things they wanted because that they
thought that was the in lieu of the
vaccine
right that was that was a regimen that
you could take so you don't have to get
vaccinated now they're totally against
that because they figured out that
science and doctors and hospitals are
for that and and i guess they're even
finding out that the regeneron doesn't
even work with the omicron variant the
[ __ ] baron as we call it here on the
show
oh [ __ ] so neil young says they can have
joe rogan or young
he wrote in a letter to his manager and
label not both
neil young demands spotify remove his
music over false information about
vaccines and it's not like this is like
an opinion right
it's not like oh well i have an opinion
about the vaccine
and what i mean by that is like oh well
this or that or details about it or
which one or you know when should we get
boosted or when should we not get
boosted you know that sort of [ __ ]
no it's complete [ __ ] utter lies
about the vaccine
like it's not enough lies are not an
opinion they're not that's not a [ __ ]
opinion and and and we need to stop this
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this country where where
just because you have the greatest
[ __ ] latest bad take opinion on
something means that it's [ __ ] true
because you posted it on spotify well
[ __ ] i'm on spotify so does that mean
every stupid [ __ ] thing that comes
out of my mouth should be gold no
[ __ ] no i'm clowning these [ __ ]
for you guys
that doesn't mean that doesn't mean that
i should be able to just spout out
[ __ ] lies
lies [ __ ] lies
so good on neil young
of course it might take neil young to
fix this problem over there at spotify
with with rogan
uh what's rex say here uh he's quoting
neil young i am doing this because
spotify is spreading fake information
about vaccines potentially causing death
to those who believe this disinformation
being spread by them he writes please
act on this immediately today and keep
me informed of the time schedule he is
not
[ __ ] around
rex is tweeting
um ours quoting
and tweeting a quote from neil young's
letter to his manager and his label
does not [ __ ] around let's see
what's amy right here neil young has
posted an open letter demanding that his
management and label remove his music
from spotify of course i want you to let
spotify know immediately today
that i went off that [ __ ] platform
that's what he's saying
now again
it sounds like he's like get that get my
[ __ ] music off there now and they're
gonna have to make a choice what do they
want they want rogan
and when rogan or they want young
what's machine pun kelly say i'm not
under the delusion that neil young is
going to change spotify's mind but what
if other artists followed suit
what if the choice isn't neil young or
joe rogan but music or propaganda hey
that's a good [ __ ] point machine pun
kelly
maybe they will follow him maybe that's
neil's plan here is to drag some of
these people into the mix here get more
people that [ __ ] stand up
stand up for truth in this goddamn
country i mean yeah joe rogan can go and
say whatever the [ __ ] he wants he has
the right to lie and [ __ ] and all
that stuff but spotify doesn't have to
amplify it
that's the point they don't have to
[ __ ] amplify it
uh let's see we got any other
angela says i choose neil young not
propaganda do you [ __ ] yeah
i would have anything over this [ __ ]
joe rogan propaganda [ __ ]
hell i'd even take joe rogan back from
10 years ago and the jerry rogan now
it's completely [ __ ] different
he built this audience and now he has to
cow down to this [ __ ] audience he's
got money to make right it's all about
profit he sold out the spotify he sold
out to his [ __ ] audience
now he's now he's got a cow town to the
[ __ ] crazies [ __ ] idiot all right
good on neil young [ __ ] joe rogan you
can tell him i said that i'll go on his
show and tell him to go [ __ ] himself
that's right i'd go on joe rogan's show
just to tell him to go [ __ ] himself
now let's see that the fda is trending
um
the fda wants uh limit use of regeneron
um
for antibody treatment
apparently uh
they're seeing data that regeneron is
not effective against the [ __ ] variant
and of course you have down in florida
you get uh ron desantis desantis that's
killed almost a hundred thousand [ __ ]
people
with his with his goddamn policies or
lack thereof
and uh
you know he was always pumping the
regeneron regeneron regeneron regeneron
well he's got stock in it probably
you know they got a profit off this the
[ __ ] death
it ain't always and you know it ain't
always about winning elections it's
always about filling the bank account
sometimes
uh
but ron desantis
was continuing to
um
want to use regeneron and the fda saying
no it doesn't [ __ ] work it's not
effective
and of course
the other thing that's trending is uh or
it was
let's see if we can find it here
speaking of the
karuna virus we're 32 minutes into the
hour
where we had here
it was on here earlier oh holocaust is
trending and jesus [ __ ] christ can't
even keep up with these [ __ ] trends
these [ __ ] people saying this dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then i gotta go
whack them down it's like [ __ ]
whack-a-mole it's like [ __ ] gqp
whack-a-mole over here in the shitless
roundup jesus christ god damn let's take
a break
and i'll be right back
after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back
to the [ __ ] list roundup where we round
up all the tweety tweets in the trendy
trend
[Music]
we're back
[Music]
and we're gonna talk about uh robert
kennedy jr again because holocaust is
trending again
he's
[ __ ] gross [ __ ] comparing uh
the the
holocaust to them oppressing themselves
the choices that they make the
consequences of the choices that they're
making they're comparing to the [ __ ]
holocaust you gross [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] disgusting let's make this
a little bigger here we watched this
video yesterday and we might go ahead
and watch it again um
but we've got we've got people here
talking about the holocaust um
oh jesus this [ __ ] idiot here we go
here's robert kennedy jr the one that
we've seen in the video and we'll go
play the [ __ ] video
i apologize for my reference to anne
frank especially the families that
suffered the holocaust horrors my
intention was to use examples of
past
barbarism to show that perils from new
technologies of control
to the extent my remarks caused hurt i
truly and deeply
sorry so he's he's sorry about his
reference to anne frank
if you guys don't know he he talked
about how anne frank got to hide in the
attic from the nazis
well i am all for anti-vaxxers hiding at
home
hide at home you dumb [ __ ]
stay the [ __ ] at home robert f kennedy
you can suck a goddamn dick all the way
up big bag of them you [ __ ]
this tweet sucks your apology sucks
because you were dead serious and you're
still serious you're just mad at the
backlash and you might have to go visit
the holocaust museum like marjorie
taylor green did you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's right robert kennedy jr will now
be known forever and ever and ever as a
big piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you did that to yourself these are
choices that you make
these are the choices that you [ __ ]
idiots are making
here's the [ __ ] video it's got three
million views already let's watch it
even in hitler germany you could you
could cross the alps into switzerland
you can hide in an attic like anne frank
did
i visited in 1962 east germany with my
father
and met people who had climbed the wall
and escaped so it was possible many died
truly but it was possible
today
the mechanisms are being put in place
and we'll make it so none of us can run
and none of us can hide
the
within five years we're going to see 415
000 low orbit satellites oh jesus
[ __ ] okay says his 65 000 satellites
alone
we'll be able to look and see this is
this is the really damn turning this
[ __ ] off [ __ ] this guy i can't
understand this [ __ ] this is this is the
problem this is the problem with this
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] apology here
let's go back to this [ __ ] idiot's
apology okay
in his apology he says i apologize for
my reference to anne frank
he doesn't apologize for all the other
[ __ ] total [ __ ] gross ass lies
that he told he apologizes because now
now people think that this [ __ ] he's
saying is offensive right
well what the [ __ ] robert why can't you
just be offensive if you want to [ __ ]
be offensive you're saying all kinds of
dumb [ __ ] about satellites and 5g and
bill gates what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
so why are you why are you just sorry
about the anne frank thing right why why
are you just sorry about that caitlyn
makes a good point here
now the right will drag him for
apologizing a win-win that's right
[Laughter]
so now he's going to get it from both
sides and the reason why he's not he's
not retracting his entire comments here
is because he's grifting off the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
guarantee it guarantees grifting off the
[ __ ] that's what meatloaf was doing
[ __ ] meatloaf was showing up at [ __ ]
anti-vax rallies and then the
[ __ ] dies of coven
and that's what people like tucker
carlson fox news all these [ __ ]
want is they want to convince these
[ __ ] idiots that not get the vaccine
so they'll continue to get covered so
we'll continue to stuff the hospital so
there'll continually be a coveted
problem
because they know they know that it's
going to take many more variants to
reach any sort of herd immunity we know
that
we know it based on uh i don't know
science
it's gonna take several [ __ ] variants
to get to hurt immunity if you people
don't get vaccinated that is what's
gonna happen and it is not like the
holocaust it is not like the sit-ins in
the south you were not oppressed you
[ __ ] idiots you were making the
choice
jews in nazi germany didn't choose to be
jewish you [ __ ]
blacks in the south didn't choose to be
black
during segregation you [ __ ]
they can't take off their skin color
stop your gross ass [ __ ] analogies it
doesn't work
and don't give me the [ __ ] that
you're you're gonna apologize for your
reference to anne frank
frankly i i
to be frank about it that is the best
analogy you made about the [ __ ] virus
go hide in your goddamn attic if you're
not gonna get the [ __ ] vaccine fine
stay the [ __ ] at home and by the way if
you're not willing to listen to the
medical community to get your [ __ ]
vaccine don't go to the hospital seeking
treatment from the medical community
you [ __ ]
stay the [ __ ] at home eat your horse
paste take your vitamin c or whatever it
is that you're taking you're borax
bass drinking your piss
and injecting yourself with your bleach
and gargling your goddamn whatever
you're doing i don't know it's hard to
keep up the [ __ ] list is long can you
imagine can you imagine someone's like
okay here's what we're gonna do we got
this vaccine to make sure that you don't
get hospitalized
with covet right like it's it's real
simple it's it's [ __ ] free they'll
even pay for you to go to the [ __ ]
clinic to get the goddamn shot like
they'll pay for you to leave work
they'll pay for your transportation
that the cost that cost of the shop is
zero to you the government we the people
have already paid for it so you can get
it to protect
your community and our country because
we want to be patriots
or here's here's the other choice or you
can drink your own piss
you got to go down to the feed store and
buy a big old tube of horse paste and
gobble on that [ __ ]
we want you to take a borap bath we're
going to send you some dirt from canada
you're going to eat that put that in
your food
you're going to gargle you're going to
gargle uh some sort of antiseptic
that'll help
and you're going to do all these things
every day four times a day
what the [ __ ] which one would you choose
because my question would be okay so how
effective is the vaccine once really
effective the vaccine's really affected
the data showing that it's really
effective i mean it's not like 100
but i mean it's basically a hundred
percent it's gonna keep you out of the
hospital
well what about the gargling you know
antiseptic drinking piss eating dirt
and taking ivermectin what's that
well
that didn't help at all
what the [ __ ] are you gonna choose this
is where we're at in this country and
that's what robert kennedy is trying to
perpetuate with his apology here he's
not actually apologizing for the [ __ ] he
did he's apologizing because people
called him out on it
i'm real sorry that people caught me in
front of a mic
being a disgusting piece of [ __ ]
that's what he's sorry about
[ __ ] robert kennedy jr
[ __ ] him he can eat a big bag of [ __ ]
horse dicks [ __ ] him okay let's let's
move on i get [ __ ] sick of this
people comparing this [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] holocaust
we're 42 minutes into the first hour
let's see what else we got here uh
there's a jim banks is trending
i promise we'll get i promise we will
get to the douchey thing we will get
there
we will get there
uh avenger resistor here says jim banks
claims president biden attacks the press
but remains silent when trump called
every reporter fake news
for not sucking up them
well i also called him the enemy of the
people i think that [ __ ] was trending
earlier too
uh let's see if we can find the uh oh
here it is joe's got it
joe's got it
the amtented
oh joe
ah barely start your tweet there the yam
tinted turd attacked
the free pass more than
2 000 times via tweet alone jim banks is
not a serious person yeah no [ __ ] jim
banks this is the screenshot of the
tweet have you ever seen a president
attack seen a president attack and
malign the free press like by nunes get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] jim
banks who what
these people really do live on a
different [ __ ] planet
they're jacking off the m ms they're
saying that joe biden attacks the media
more than more than any other break get
the [ __ ] out of here we are we were born
at night but not last night you dumb
[ __ ] how do these people still
believe these [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] is it even possible
jesus christ
they would go to rallies
they would go to rallies and he would
point at the cameras they turned the
cameras off which they didn't they
didn't turn the cameras off they had the
[ __ ] red light on
i mean he's on live tv pointing at the
media saying they turned the cameras off
then they would turn around and
you know boo the press and treat the
press like [ __ ] they'd threaten the
[ __ ] press get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
the press has probably never been more
attacked by any other group of people
than [ __ ] trump supporters ever in
the history of ever ever
let alone a [ __ ] president jim banks
you [ __ ] what's adam kinzinger say here
thought this was a parody me
adam there is no way the real jim banks
tweeted this given his position on covet
etc oh
but he he did it's real what is this is
this different
what is it when it was this
oh this is from january 9th so this is
stupid [ __ ] that jim banks says maybe we
should make a [ __ ] segment stupid
[ __ ] gym bank says
this is a catastrophe we need to figure
out what's going on i don't even know
i'm not even [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm not even
i'll i'll give adam the [ __ ] credit
even though i'm not a fan of adam
kinzinger [ __ ] adam kinser everyone's
like oh he's a hero he's a he you know
he's a hero now like today like we'll
take it i'll take his a
that he's an american patriot in the
moment now about january 6 but he's not
he didn't vote for voting rights he
voted no he voted no for people in this
country had the right to vote that's
what he voted no on uh yoda says uh yam
titted turd
my ass was laughing off yeah
oh [ __ ] that dude
uh let's see oh gabe's gabe's got one
already
he's not on the show
but he's working but he's also tweeting
i see you gabe i see you
jim banks and every other republican are
outraged
at the president that trump set
the only difference is biden apologized
for saying yeah biden shouldn't
apologize though
he shouldn't have
he shouldn't apologized
he should not have apologized
[ __ ] that guy
he's a stupid son of a [ __ ] he
shouldn't apologize for that i mean you
say the truth you say the truth it's
it's the tough [ __ ] that it's the truth
that you're a stupid son of a [ __ ] i
don't know what to tell you i don't know
what the [ __ ] to do okay um here's
here's uh gabe's posting this i think i
think this is where
um this is the proof and the pudding
type thing like oh you guys are upset
about you know this thing wu-tang is for
the children and posted this video of
[ __ ] here the yam
as joe says the yam titted turd
proposal cuts the hell out of taxes i
don't give a damn he gets the nomination
they're gonna sue his ass up we'll beat
the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ] out of them let
them beat the [ __ ] out of isis also yeah
they're ripping the [ __ ] out of there
we're gonna knock the [ __ ] out of myself
they're gonna knock their [ __ ] out yeah
whoever the hell brought this mike
system don't the son of a [ __ ] to put
him yeah the son of a [ __ ]
but it's political [ __ ] yeah he said
he's a [ __ ] yeah and you can tell them
to go [ __ ] themselves you're not gonna
raise that [ __ ] price
listen your
what kind of people do we have
running for office a voter first needs
to sincerely know and it sounds like a
proposal
thank you wu-tang for posting that look
i'm not opposed to a president cussing
at all uh even even leaning into the mic
i'm okay with joe biden leaning into the
mic and saying you're a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
you are a stupid son of a [ __ ] i'm not
opposed to that me but [ __ ] i don't give
a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] but i i find
it really funny that they're going to
attack they're going to attack [ __ ]
joe biden for say son of a [ __ ] you
know because it's unpresidential or it's
unbecoming of a president or unbecoming
of a person or whatever the [ __ ] their
attack is get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] no one in this country is
going oh clutching their pearls
and understanding other [ __ ] issues
that are important like
people aren't [ __ ] worried about joe
biden saying son of a [ __ ] frankly it's
the best thing he's done in a couple
[ __ ] weeks is to lash out and say
[ __ ] that guy he's a stupid son of a
[ __ ] because he asks a stupid [ __ ]
question he asks is inflation good for
politics like yeah you [ __ ] idiot you
know the [ __ ] answer that question
you dumbass uh wu-tang says when the
republicans and the morons over at fox
news come out of the woodwork to cry
yeah because they are going to cry more
about biden calling douchey a stupid sob
just show them
show them this trump compilation thank
you
thank you wu tang did i retweet that i
think it yet yep did i give credit yeah
i gave credit okay just make sure reddit
we give credit did i give gabe credit
for that one
i'll give him credit here too i gave him
credit for the first one you know he's
not on the show today
but i'll give him credit for it gabe
your fans are missing you over here on
the show if you're [ __ ] listening
they're missing you all right let's um
let's go let's go to the let's go to the
the douchey thread i want to do that
now that we're talking about it [ __ ] it
gucci
um
george sakai says biden rarely drops
curses but when he does it's a douchey
oh george
god damn
i i don't know if that's the tweet of
the day or not but it's pretty [ __ ]
close that's pretty [ __ ] close who
likes that tweet god damn go retweet
that [ __ ] go to my [ __ ] timeline and
retweet that uh paul paul here has uh i
think he posted this is something peter
ducey reporting live from the white
house
[Laughter]
that's a good
uh paul's always got that you got the
good art you got the good art friend you
got the good art keep it up don't stop
don't stop
can't stop won't stop paul for democracy
these are good all right um let's go
back let's see what else we got here
dude
oh because there was more than one ducey
news yesterday of course jin saki likes
to slam dunk this [ __ ] in the
trash did you guys know i speaking of
jinsaki i heard this news yesterday i've
seen a video
politics girl has jin saki on her
podcast if you guys are jinsaki fans you
gotta i'm gonna go watch i'm hoping it's
um it's on video it's usually on youtube
but yeah i think you can download it on
your your directories
um but um
uh she she's she's jen saki the press
secretary is going to be on lee
mcgowan's politic girls
um podcast so go check that out let's
see let's see what this is
ducey time does the president think it's
a big deal that today that the dow is
down at one point more than 1100 points
and then of course she dunks him in the
trash let's listen to her just [ __ ]
scorch earth this dumb [ __ ] do you think
he has like some sort of
fetish where you know you know i know i
know tucker carlson likes to jack off
the m m's but i wonder if i wonder if uh
ducey here likes to um
likes to get tied up and
and spanked by redheads i don't know i'm
just i'm just saying that i'm it might
be a thing first on the markets does the
president think it's a big deal that
today the dow jones is down
at one point more than 1100 points
what's funny is is they think joe
biden's sitting around the oval office
watching the [ __ ] stock market minute
by minute
that's the funny part is these [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
are [ __ ]
and caitlyn says public humiliation
fetish that probably is um mj says she
already listened and it's awesome so you
listen
it's already dropped the podcast has
already dropped was it this morning or
something it must be must've been really
early this morning thanks mj for giving
us a review on on the i'm gonna go watch
that i'm gonna go watch jin saki on
politics girl
it's probably very [ __ ] good but um
i lost my train of thought i was i was
talking about steve doocy here oh oh yes
the stock market they think they think
they think joe biden is sitting around
in the [ __ ] in the white house
you know watching the [ __ ] cable news
channels watching watching the [ __ ]
you know bloomberg or whatever
cnbc watching the stock market and like
oh my god oh my god the stock market's
down two points oh it's up four oh it's
down two oh you know who was doing that
you know what dude like joe said the the
the am did a turd
was doing that joe biden doesn't he's
not worried about the stock minute stock
market minute for a minute you dumb
other [ __ ] he's got a lot more
[ __ ] [ __ ] to do
he's trying to [ __ ] figure out what
the hell putin's doing
to try to not because i think putin's
trying to test biden that's what i think
i think well i mean he's trying to test
western democracy um but biden is the
president united states which is the
helm of the western democracy and the
reason why he didn't test trump is
because he didn't need to test trump he
knew what trump stood he knew he had
trump in the palm of his hand
and the other thing too is trump doesn't
represent western democracy he never did
he represented autocracy that's why
[ __ ] putin loved him and he didn't
have to challenge him
trump never represented
western democracy at all he's a [ __ ]
fascist he's an autocrat he wants to be
a dictator no no one questions that
i mean besides the [ __ ] sheep the
delusional brainwashed sheep
so biden is not sitting in the oval
office worried moment to moment what the
stock market's doing you [ __ ] idiot
well to start with we focus on the
trends in the economy not any one day
and any single indicator unlike his
predecessor the president does not look
at the stock market as a means by which
to judge the economy i would note that
the market is up around 15 percent
compared to when president biden took
office
but our measure of success is really how
real working families are doing whether
they have a little breathing room
whether they have a job that delivers
some dignity and a paycheck that can
support they can support a family on and
we've seen a great deal of progress made
on that front thank you
thank you for
spanking me that's fantastic
uh thanks curtis for for the for the
clip
thanks curtis for the clip do i follow
curtis i don't know
let's check this out do you guys do your
new homework on these people when you
follow him
managing anders is news busters
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know who curtis hancock is or
hawk hawk curtis hawk i don't know all
right let's uh let's go back to this
thread i want to get to the [ __ ] um
the meat and potatoes of this [ __ ]
um what's jack say here president biden
just called peter ducey a stupid son of
a [ __ ] raise your hand if you agree yes
he is a stupid son of a [ __ ]
he is a stupid son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
i want to see the [ __ ] clip where's
the clip there's gotta be the clip in
here
the clip of biden saying it here it is
brian's got it here
this is the clip
that biden had apologies
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
brian says at the end of the biden photo
op when reporters shouted questions
hoping he'd respond fox peter douchey
asked do you think inflation is a
political liability in the midterms
uh biden deadpan
it's a great asset more inflation what a
stupid son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right there's there's there's the
there's the video if you want to put it
on
[Music]
if you want to put it on a loop
or 55 minutes into the first hour and
we're not even done with peter ducey yet
douchey peter douchey
oh here's some this is another clip of
of
peter douchey i'm talking to john mccain
and john mccain you know
he couldn't stand this uh wu-tang says
john mccain is also not a fan of that
stupid son of a [ __ ] peter douchey
let's listen to this relationship with
the president frayed to the point that
you
are not going to support anything that
comes to you and that's how would you
say something that's stupid
huh my job is united states
you stupid son of a [ __ ]
oh my god
oh man that's a dumb question
well uh you know is it a fair question
no no it's a dumb question and he's a
stupid son of a [ __ ] your son is a
stupid son of a [ __ ] that's a story
here
the only reason why this [ __ ] is
at fox news anyway is because his dad
sits on fox and friends
and gas lights the nation every [ __ ]
morning every [ __ ] morning he's
gaslighting in the nation uh what's
avenger resisters say here with one of
our favorites if you're calling for the
pres that if you're calling for
president biden to be impeached because
he called peter ducey a son of a [ __ ]
but voted for trump and his locker room
talk you're a hypocritical son of a
[ __ ] abso [ __ ] lutely yeah the whole
let's go brandon grab em by the [ __ ]
crowd yeah they're offended that joe
biden said son of a [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] you people
are a bunch of [ __ ] snowflakes you
can't handle someone saying a [ __ ]
curse word get the [ __ ] out of here the
only reason why we [ __ ] and moan and
complained about trump [ __ ] uh
cursing is because you people act like
it's the worst thing that ever happens
in the world until your [ __ ] orange
deity does it get the [ __ ] out of here
we're tired of this garbage
scarily not so breaking peter douchey is
still a stupid slap a [ __ ]
he's still a stupid son of a [ __ ] even
this morning
even this morning he's a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
okay
let's see what else what kind of good
stuff do we get
aaron aaron post this video i know let's
see what the let's see what this is this
is this is this someone talking to peter
douchey shut up [ __ ]
shut up [ __ ]
oh thanks aaron for posting that
fantastic
i didn't even think of that you know you
got all these things you got to think of
right
okay let's see let's see
um liam nissan
i can't believe biden would mock peter
ducey's disability like that what a jerk
what a [ __ ] jerk
that joe biden is to mock him like that
what is this
the hell is this
let's see
okay let's go back here
we got some good ones this this douchey
thing we could do this all day long oh
here's one of our favorites of course i
um
if you think peter ducey is stupid son
of a [ __ ] we should be friends mayo you
are my friend
my friend my friend
mayo is my friend she's one of my
favorites one of my favorites on this
whole [ __ ] app that account right
there that account right there is one of
my favorite accounts on the whole
[ __ ] app and it should be yours too
you know she got her her original
account suspended and she had to make
this account so go follow this account
you got to follow it give her support
over there
because she's like a tweet warrior
she's constantly with him she doesn't
stop she's a [ __ ] tweet machine we
love you mayo okay let's see here what's
wrong got here
is this oh this is um this is tucker's
little
what a nasty old man
[Laughter]
oh watch this
what a nasty old man
what a nasty old man they really are
[ __ ] butthurt
oh my god i guess
i guess i guess biden doesn't share
um tucker's eminem fetish so he's nasty
oh christ let's see what else we got
surely we got some [ __ ] footage of
fox news losing their [ __ ] minds
over this stuff didn't they lose their
minds last night couldn't they didn't
they oh yeah here we go all right so
here erin posted this clip uh but it
looks like it's
looked like it's on hannity
um so let's let's watch the oh
oh let's watch him let's watch him cry
let's let's do that
we have some news tonight
uh after
years of clips of the president and i
kind of mixing it up on the camera yeah
you see here caitlyn points it out here
too um on the screen here he was smiling
when he said stupid son of a [ __ ] of
course he was making the joke i mean
that that he would even ask the question
and he called him a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
but it says angry biden curses out
curses out peter deuce which is not what
happened he didn't curse him out it's
not like peter ducey asked questions
like look here you [ __ ] i mean
the the clip we seen from john mccain
that was more of a cursing
than the joe biden thing the joe biden
just like oh this [ __ ] guy this
[ __ ] guy
you [ __ ] stupid son of a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you talking about angry
biden curses out peter ducey get out of
here
you people really are [ __ ] dumb and
you think we're [ __ ] dumb to bleed
this [ __ ] stupid headline campaign
trail and during the transition and here
at the white house
uh within about an hour of that exchange
he called my cell phone
and uh he said it's nothing personal pal
and we went back and forth
it's nothing personal it's just it's
just your personality i can't help it i
can't help your stupid son of a [ __ ]
what am i supposed to do about it
just kind of
moving moving forward and i made sure to
tell him that i'm always going to try to
ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking yeah you're gonna ask stupid
[ __ ] questions because you're a
stupid son of a [ __ ] we know what we
know what the game is
we know who you work for
we know we're not [ __ ] dumb we're on
top of you you stupid idiot [ __ ] and
uh he said you've got to
and that's a quote from the president so
i'll keep doing it
all right i want to be your negotiator
here and i would like to negotiate a
20-minute sit-down with you and biden
one-on-one i think that would be
you know
i'm a christian i believe in forgiveness
she apologize
uh he cleared the air and i appreciated
it we had a nice call
he's that's not an answer did he
apologize i'm a christian
he he said it's not i love that i am a
christian i'm a christian you are not
you are not you people pretending to be
christians all this time you're not
[ __ ] christians
[ __ ] support that [ __ ]
as joe says
yam titted turd oh my god
you got me joe you got me okay let's see
uh what else we got
do is there anything else in here uh
that maybe maybe we should uh
go over
[ __ ] lauren beaubert's [ __ ] and i'm
not even gonna read that [ __ ] oh irishy
girl
tomorrow when peter doozy asked ginsaki
another stupid question
no she responds stupid son of a [ __ ]
say what
[Laughter]
by the way by the way i uh i think i put
the link here in the chat uh to the
politics girl don't go watch it yet stay
here on this show first but uh i put the
let's see where where to go i put it in
the chat here somewhere
i'm looking for and i'm looking for it
um
whoa it's way up there you guys are you
guys are on fire today here it is um
there's there the links in the chat here
if you if you guys want to go find the
politics girl um podcast it's on google
podcast you can also probably go to
midastouch.com or you go to the midas
touch she's uh that that that podcast is
a minus touch production you can go to
um their their youtube page probably or
you can just go to leah just just tweet
and ty just search it and tweet politics
girl
or go to youtube and search it you'll be
able to find uh she interviewed jen saki
um i'm gonna go watch that after the
show okay let's see here
um
oh here we go
joe joe gives us another reminder
a reminder when every talking head at
fox news clutches their pearls because
biden called ducey light
a stupid son of a [ __ ]
that they said nothing when the former
guy spent years attacking journalists
that he didn't like especially women
yeah no [ __ ]
but hypocrisy is the brand after all
let's listen to the clip she posted here
what a stupid question that is
what a stupid question but i watch you a
lot you ask a lot of stupid questions
why don't you act in a little more
positive it's always trying to my
question to you did you get you and you
know what that's why nobody trusts the
media anymore that's why how's that
going to end you didn't hear me that's
why you used to work for the times and
now you work for somebody else look let
me tell you something
be nice
don't
don't be threatening
include the congressional black [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well i would i tell you what you want to
set up the meeting what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you see it right there
you're right there it's not hard to see
you [ __ ] idiot so when you're
clutching your pearls and whining and
crying the biden said [ __ ]
get over it
cry more let's go brandon crowd this is
the [ __ ] let's go brandon let's go
brandon crowd is crying that joe biden
said the word [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we don't need this garbage all right
let's take a quick break we'll be right
back after these messages
[Music]
you sit your ass down shut the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and every one you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binder is brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of
women the tony michaels podcast
wednesdays at 4 p.m eastern 3 p.m
central watch live on youtube on twitter
and twitch download on apple and spotify
now here's tony
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
shitless roundup
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the twenty trends of the day speaking of
boycott we just seen the boycott binder
i know you guys like of all of gabe's
commercials we're gonna try to get him
to a bunch more how many more do you
guys want you want like 10 more 20 more
um i'll get him to do as many as you
guys want you just you just tell me the
number
we'll get we'll get him to make those
commercials i think i think he's
actually got a couple in the works
that he's been working on
uh so hopefully we'll have those
commercials ready we also have a great
interview um this week um we're supposed
to record that this afternoon uh so
stick around this week for um the
interview you guys know we used to do
the interview every wednesday the tony
michaels podcast used to be every
wednesday but now in the afternoon but
now we're doing it every single day
noon eastern 11 central two hours a day
every single weekday and we're going to
throw in these interviews boneheaded a
week is going to be on friday we have
the shitless roundup during most of the
show because uh there's so much [ __ ] to
round up we have poppins from other
people i think tomorrow we're gonna have
a special pop-in uh we have scheduled uh
you guys remember we had an interview
from rachel bitkoffer a bit of coffer
bit coffer um i always put your name
rachel is gonna be back
on
the show
um probably with a pop and i i'm hoping
tomorrow we can get her on sometime um
we're gonna talk about some of the
things that that she's been yelling and
screaming about some some of these
things like how to frame up these
arguments uh not only for the economy
and inflation but the coronavirus and
some of these others to make sure we get
our messaging on point but we also need
some strategic outrage we need all these
democratic institutions these
pro-democracy institutions out there to
work together to fight for 2022. so
hopefully rachel can come tomorrow and
give us some
um some more insight into that we had an
interview you guys should go watch it um
subscribe to the youtube channel it's
over there um of course the the podcast
that she was on
is on youtube of course but also also
just the interview alone is on there as
well so if you wanted to watch me and
gabe i think we talked about cat turds
i really i think that's i think that's
what we led into
with rachel bittikoffer the political
strategy just from strike back we were
talking about cat turds and i think i
think that the context was
you know not to get too far in the weeds
here but the context of the character
conversation was that are drinking their
piss maybe they'll be digging in the
litter box for cat turds
for coronavirus you know um um treatment
yeah i don't know i mean yeah i could
see how you know if someone drinking
their own piss could think that cat
turds are a good treatment you know
eating their horse pace uh gargling
antiseptic and injecting bleach
you know eating dirt from from a
landfill in canada i think
i think i think they would go as far as
to eat cat turds i mean they really
would especially if it was posted on
facebook they'd be like whoa facebook
said facebook said cat turds so if you
want to have the cat turd
um content before the rachel interview
go watch the podcast episode with rachel
in it i believe it is episode um i think
50
oh today we're 61 i don't know i'm
losing track where it's we're episode
number 51 of the tony michaels podcast
or you can just watch um her interview
alone um but hopefully we'll have her on
tomorrow and i think we're gonna have
her in the uh the the first hour is
where we're gonna have rachel come in
tomorrow for for a bit of time to to uh
break down some messaging and stuff so
don't miss that put that on your
schedule tomorrow morning
again
noon eastern 11 central
right here youtube twitter twitch the
other nice part about having the podcast
on every single day now i don't know if
you guys noticed this but we put the
podcast now the show is on the podcast
directories every single day whereas
before it was just the wednesday show it
was just the wednesday show that went up
on the podcast directory so spotify
apple uh google you could only download
it over there
on wednesdays after the show because we
do the shows live
so but but now now you'll get a download
every single weekday so there'll be five
a week two hours five of them
so you'll be able to download those so
go find your favorite directory and
leave us a review there not don't [ __ ]
around and leave a bad review leave a
good review right
five stars say some good [ __ ] you know i
don't know i don't know what you say
just say some something great right like
yay
hooray i don't know i don't know what
you're writing there but leave a review
for the podcast as well
uh so we we just seen gabe's commercial
the the boycott binder and i guess i
guess these [ __ ] idiots uh let's make
this bigger again our boycotting walmart
that's a hashtag i don't know
i don't know what's going on um
i guess uh
is this a sign mark mark has this posted
roll on the floor laughing imagine being
so intellectually inept that you
actually believe that you're
boycotting walmart because they're
tyrants when actually walmart is
boycotting you because you're stupid
this is perfect so it looks like this is
a picture from a walmart i don't know i
don't know if this is real or not it
says notice starting january 24th due to
government mandates we will ensure that
all customers 13 and up are properly
vaccinated when entering the store
uh looks like there's some kind of qr
code so they're they're requiring a
vaccine passport i don't know if this is
here or somewhere else
but i think it's funny that people would
boycott walmart
and like mark said when they're actor
boycotting you they don't want you in
their store what don't you [ __ ]
understand
what don't you get and it's funny that
manga would be boycotting
uh walmart oh it's
okay it looks like it's walmart in
canada right because uh last last week
it was um ronald mcdonald house you
remember this last week there in canada
they were gonna they were gonna boycott
ronald mcdonald house and then they were
gonna boycott mcdonald's so here we have
maga maga in this country
trump supporters gonna boycott walmart
and mcdonald's get the [ __ ] out of here
you [ __ ] people live off walmart
mcdonald's what the [ __ ] would you do
without walmart mcdonald's you toothless
[ __ ] rednecks get out of here i know
you [ __ ] type jesus christ half my
family's [ __ ] trump supporters and
they [ __ ] they
they love mcdonald's they eat it six
times a week
and where do you think they [ __ ] get
all their garbage all their junk they
get it from wally world come on the [ __ ]
out of here you people are gonna boycott
walmart and mcdonald's this ain't gonna
last more than two [ __ ] seconds not
two [ __ ] seconds
jesus let's see what uh jewish gender
resistor says if manga decides truly
to boycott walmart where where were they
shot from i mean people at walmart has
essentially always been a maga rally
at the same time a texas woman tried
buying a baby at walmart because it
had blonde hair and blue eyes
i did not see nazi that coming oh [ __ ]
oh man
um i'm scared to look at these pictures
but we're gonna
we're gonna take a gander oh look at
this guy that that's really that this is
i think this is the website people of
walmart i know you guys have seen this
this has been around for a long time um
but walmart is really entertaining if
you go to walmart and it's really
entertaining like you know like at night
uh here's another oh yeah sexy
confederates there whoosh uh
uh let's see oh this guy's just carrying
around a confederate flag in walmart
what the [ __ ] who
who in the [ __ ] who in the [ __ ] takes
their flag into walmart
what is wrong with these people
oh yeah here's here's this guy he's real
cute right to cut off jeans cowboy boots
confederate uh durag and the confederate
[ __ ] cut off sleeve shirt gonna buy
some cigs here he's at the cigarette
counter this lady's having none of that
[ __ ]
jesus these people
oh they're gonna boycott mcdonald's and
walmart are you [ __ ] kidding me okay
good luck
let's see what else we get
uh
here's steve let's see what steve has to
say right wing dummies are threatening
to boycott walmart over them requiring
mask
i've seen this before and it won't
happen
um it won't happen like they won't
boycott
um because i believe that why rednecks
are boycotts are pointless let's listen
steve has some good some good points
let's listen the following is a clip
from my new comedy special secret
optimist and anytime anything
progressive happens there will be a fake
redneck boycott
now what i mean by this
is
so trump banned immigrants
and then starbucks came out and they
said hey we're gonna hire 10 000
refugees
all these xenophobic rednecks went on
twitter
we're not gonna drink starbucks anymore
and i was like
where the [ __ ] did you drink starbucks
and if you did didn't you stop when they
had a red cup
right that was like three boycotts ago
wasn't it
and then
one of the actors in hamilton had some
words from mike pence during a
performance
all these blindly patriotic rednecks
went on twitter
they were like we're not gonna go see
hamilton anymore
and i was like
how the [ __ ] did you get hamilton
tickets
[Applause]
what are you talking about you can't
boycott something you don't use we're
not gonna drink starbucks we're not
gonna go see hamilton we get a boycott
next portland oregon shut up you don't
use these things
the one boycott that could have worked
was the budweiser boycott
during the super bowl budweiser had an
end and the point of the ad was
budweiser saying hey you know our
company was founded by immigrants like
most things in this country so maybe
take a step back for a second consider
the ramifications of your actions
all these rednecks went on twitter
they're like we're not gonna drink
budweiser anymore
and i was like
yes you are
what are you talking about no one
chooses to drink budweiser that's not a
choice you're born that way
look i we live in a very tolerant i can
confirm being from missouri that it is
it is a requirement here it's like water
here you have to drink budweiser bud
like natural light some some sort of
anheuser-busch it is true i'm right he's
not lying we accept you for who you are
whatever an adult does and the privacy
of their own inner tube is up to them
i think that's in leviticus somewhere
i know jay-z's baby yeah jay-z's baby
but budweiser was spelled wrong in the
hashtag
that's true that's real
the word budweiser is spelled
b-w-e-i-s-e-r but they spelled the
w-i-s-e-r like the word wiser
particularly ironic like how
do you misspell your own political
movement how's that even possible
you guys remember that famous speech
from martin luther king right i have a
dram you guys remember that
oh [ __ ]
who thinks who thinks we should get
steve on the show this is fantastic who
thinks we should get steve on the show
retweet um
thank you steve for the for the comic
relief there he does great stand up by
the way
um he's got he's got a really good one
on guns that i've watched before i don't
know if you guys seen that uh here
here's eugene eugene i i think he was in
the chat earlier he might still be there
he might not
i fully endorse anti-vaxxers in their
boycott walmart
it will make shopping there much safer
without bio terrorists trying to kill us
with their nasty ass infected meth
mouths yes
yes exactly this is the whole stay the
[ __ ] at home if you don't like this [ __ ]
if you don't like to you can't go to
restaurants and get [ __ ] cheesecake
at the cheesecake factory and you can't
go to walmart and mcdonald's or whatever
stay the [ __ ] at home
if you're not gonna get vaccinated and
you're not gonna wear a mask whatever
whatever is the situation that we're in
at the time because of you dumb [ __ ]
stay the [ __ ] at home
that's vaccinated people and
people wearing masks we've been doing
this [ __ ] for over two [ __ ] years
trying to protect you people
because you're dumb [ __ ]
and here we are trying to deal with you
boycotting [ __ ] over and over here's
wu-tang same sign
boycott walmart's trending because this
sign out of quebec right and this is in
canada not in the united states
and i'm like damn do this here and maybe
i'll finally step foot into one of these
stores
so wu tang saying hey you put a sign up
i'll actually come in the [ __ ] store
because that's the craziest part too
like they're boycotting walmart because
you can't go in the store like walmart
has one of the most
one of the best curbside services now
like like you you can buy anything you
want at walmart they'll bring all the
[ __ ] junk that you buy there they'll
bring it right out to your car and stick
it in there you don't have to go in and
walk around put the [ __ ] in your car
[ __ ] check out go out put the [ __ ] in
your car realize you forgot four things
go back in [ __ ] that [ __ ] you ain't
gonna put the cart in the little [ __ ]
you know the the buggy corral you ain't
gotta do any of that [ __ ] they bring it
right out and put it right in your
[ __ ] car right in your [ __ ] car
they'll put it in there for you
god damn
oh
they're boycotting walmart and they're
boycotting mcdonald's
[Laughter]
oh man it's gonna be a good year this
year what a great year it's gonna be
we're 23 minutes into
the second hour uh emmy the enemy of the
people was trending uh let's see let's
see what we got let's see what we got
going on here um it looks like um
marsha blackburn was tweeting about joe
biden joe fighting oh god he's attacking
the press by saying they're tough and
they ask stupid [ __ ] questions they
do ask stupid [ __ ] questions
joe biden is let's let's go over and
let's let's give this [ __ ] idiot her
do
senator marsha blackburn says joe biden
is attacking the free and fair press oh
[ __ ]
looking to forward to the outrage from
maddow
and
joyanne reed what the
about what
about what because he called the stupid
son of a [ __ ] a stupid son of a [ __ ]
get out of here with that [ __ ] what does
claire bear say here i recall your cult
leader cursed cursing a lot even at
reporters
go to a corner
oh thank you
thank you claire
we read it we give credit thank you
claire let's retweet that too
see we got any other good
any other good ones of course it's all
memes of trump cussing
your tweet sucks by the way
yes i want to tweet that did i did i put
that her tweet didn't suck did i give
her credit like i read thank you no i
surely i didn't i better not have i want
to give joy here credit though uh hi
senator
hello you can come on my show you
dumbass you don't have to tweet at me i
bet i bet joy would have [ __ ] marsha
blackburn on her show and rip her a new
goddamn [ __ ] what do you think i
think she would i don't think she'd
steer away from that hi senator may i
ask you
why you referred to black judicial
nominee as having a rap sheet
due to some past speeding tickets also
can you point to me
to your
condemnations of donald trump or calling
the press the enemy of the people
you're welcome discussing the readout
look at that i i
she totally would have her on
she wouldn't go on marshall blackburn
wouldn't go on
thank you joy for your tweet
uh let's see here
what else we got here
and the enemy of the people oh mayo
always keeps it nice short and simple so
we can all understand donald trump is
the enemy of the people
yeah
that's how autocracy works they are the
enemy of the masses
they want to control everything ah damn
it
see we we jumped ahead here okay let's
get back in there
where were we at where we at the
timeline here
well let's just let's just start here
here's scary larry he's got to have a
good one too i'm old enough to remember
when donald trump called the free press
the enemy the people over and over and
over and over again and wouldn't just
him they would parrot him they would
[ __ ] parrot him over and over and
over again and we continue continuing
continuing to continue
to
[ __ ] beat this drum what does eric
swalwell say here he expressed an
opinion about one reporter
but where were you
when the former guy was describing the
free press that serves and perhaps the
most critical of the
perhaps the most critical of the pillars
of our freedom
in our sacred republic as the enemy of
the people
um
he's talking to chris pack here i don't
know let's see what this tweet says
he's responding here this is absolutely
unconscionable assault on our free first
amendment and on the free press and
serves as perhaps the most critical of
the parents breeding blah blah blah it's
truly a dark bay in the history get the
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me
you [ __ ] serious it's a dark day in
the history of the united states when
joe biden leans in and calls that dumb
[ __ ] a stupid son of a [ __ ] and
the entire country goes yep he sure is a
stupid son of a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you are a dumb
[ __ ] your tweet [ __ ] sucks
and yes twitter yes i want to tweet that
[ __ ] see this happens see what happens i
tweet this is what i tweet this is all i
tweet is this bad i don't know i mean
i'd say [ __ ] list
but it says your tweet sucks what what
that's that's [ __ ] facts i don't know
what to tell him i mean it's not an
opinion it's facts because i believe it
i believe it wholeheartedly that your
[ __ ] tweet sucks that it becomes a
fact that's how it works right that's
how we work in this world now your tweet
sucks featured on today's [ __ ] list
roundup why is what's so bad about that
what's so horrible about that huh i
don't get it no i don't want to [ __ ]
edit it tw twitter
no i don't want to tweet that [ __ ] [ __ ]
him okay
thank you eric for your
for your explanation of chris pack's
dumbass tweet
let's see what does andrew have to say
here trump calls the press
the enemy of the people mocks disabled
reporters and gold star family and cites
violence against journalists cages
infants
permits and insurrection and kills
hundred and seventy thousand americans
manga
biden accurately calls
ducey a stupid son of a [ __ ] manga
civility
you have you or you're tearing apart our
country
[ __ ] [ __ ] what a bunch of goddamn
snowflakes can't handle the word [ __ ]
get that you remember you remember when
uh when he was talking about people
kneeling in the nfl in solidarity with
black people in this country being
murdered by [ __ ] police officers when
colin kaepernick respected the flag and
respected the national anthem by
kneeling in his protest
to the anthem yeah he sat on the [ __ ]
bench he sat on the [ __ ] bench
and someone a veteran told him hey to
respect the flag please kneel and he did
in his protest he was doing he was
kneeling out of respect you [ __ ]
idiots
and then the president united states the
as joe says the yam titted turd
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy
pants stands in front of a microphone
and said get that stupid son of a [ __ ]
off the field you remember that one huh
where was the tearing a part of our
country then where were you so upset
then at the president saying that [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here you people are
really [ __ ] dumb
you people are really [ __ ] dumb to
think that we're that stupid that we
can't remember that [ __ ]
it's on camera it's on film we got the
videos you stupid bastards okay fred
says four years of trump calling
the press enemy of the people telling
reporters they were stupid and
encouraging his followers to scream at
them in rallies i said this earlier he
points at the camera saying they turn
the cameras off the [ __ ] the media's
enemy people go get him get him yelling
scream at him send death threats
one dumb scene of a [ __ ] and head glenn
heads for the fainting couch what a joke
that's right um i'm gonna retweet this
and we're gonna read this tweet from uh
schmidt glenwald whatever his name is
that [ __ ] idiot
um ron has it here this is what the
nazis did in quotes what what is that oh
oh this is this is glenn this is glenn
calling calling non-fascist fascist
let's give ron credit here because i
know i'm going to want to already oh
that's going back here
hmm
let's see he says grave attack on press
freedom this is what the nazis did what
the nazis
leaned into the mic and called a stupid
question a person who asked a really
stupid [ __ ] question the stupid son
of a [ __ ] and that's fascism you are
[ __ ] dumb trying to [ __ ] bang up
the press and get them not to have press
passes
ducey gets to ask biden questions
if trump had his way he would have made
sure that most of those questions
weren't even asking his presidents don't
you [ __ ] get it
you [ __ ] really are stupid this is
what the nazis did and sight hatred
amongst those who challenge them get the
[ __ ] out of here solidarity with
peter ducey it's it's a dangerous time
to tell the truth in america tell the
truth what do you he asked him a
question
and joe biden's response is that's a
stupid [ __ ] question you dumb son of
a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you want
i hope all i hope all the press freedom
groups and their other outlets will
condemn this attack attack on what
people really are [ __ ] weak to claim
that you want to be strong and you want
to be tough and you got to show the
world that you're tough you guys really
are melting into puddles of [ __ ] ice
cream over joe biden saying the word son
of a [ __ ] really [ __ ] fast it really
is [ __ ] pathetic
what's joe say here i prefer a president
who calls one reporter a stupid son of a
[ __ ] than a president who calls an
entire american media the enemy of the
people but that's just me oh it's not
just you joe
it's not just you there's a lot of
[ __ ] out there
oh duty to warn i you mean like calling
the uh let's see jim banks have you ever
this is the [ __ ] one from earlier
have you ever seen a president attacking
the line the free press like joe biden
has you mean like calling the press the
enemy of the people crying fake news
every day
uh plotting when they are assaulted and
trying to prosecute and sue them
how stupid
does jim banks think we are gaslight
alert no [ __ ]
gaslight is just [ __ ] absolute
stupidity i mean they're trying to you
know they do this they project this [ __ ]
they project this [ __ ] we're we're 33
minutes into the second hour here
yep oh let's see uh let's see if there's
anything else we're going to do boycott
walmart jim banks fda neil young kate
mckinnon and laura ingram oh my god
i almost
i almost forgot
about the kate mckinnon and laura ingram
thread we also have rupert murdoch shock
chuck todd and fake news training let's
see if those trends are still are still
pumping away here did trump is trending
it looks like
did trump [ __ ] his
britches uh let's let's tweet that you
guys want to see a live tweet right here
on here
let's see
did trump
[ __ ] oh
there you go
did trump [ __ ] his britches again there
you go
it's in the trend what do you want me to
do
what do you want me to do i got to tweet
some nasty you know toilet humor what
what am i supposed to do
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone's talking here
let's see
uh yoda says manga [ __ ] your feelings
um
talk about
caitlyn says tony it's coded language
remember what the neo-nazis parroted
that they thought they heard from him
same [ __ ] yeah
yep
same [ __ ] it's all coded language you
know they they know they know the code
they know the code for sure
uh let's see
um what's elsa what is this did trump
thing is this just because he's a
[ __ ] idiot
is that what this is
let's go back what the hell is going on
there we go okay
browser problems
did trump john don lewis says did why
did trump have children involved in
running the united states government did
you see this he's bitching oh they're
going after my children they're going
after my children they go after the
children that's funny they're like yeah
your your [ __ ] adult
daughter and son who was involved in
this [ __ ] yeah they're going to go after
your quote unquote children they're
going after oh they're going to attack
children children
[ __ ] are you tall i mean yeah they're
your kids
but they've been adult buffoons for a
long [ __ ] time okay let's see what
else do we have here
did trump did trump
i don't know
i don't know what the what the point of
the did trump thing is if there's
something in particular just because
everyone's see there you go did trump
[ __ ] his britches again
[Laughter]
go retweet that i i think yeah midas
lisa said retweeted
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
i can't help the toilet humor what am i
supposed to do what the [ __ ] am i i'm
the [ __ ] guy what am i supposed to do
okay let's go
um let's see what jon stewart is now
trending temper tantrum joe is trending
of course i wrote a tweet about that
earlier uh oh mine's at the top oh it's
at the top tamper tan temper tan jesus
christ temper tantrum joe is trending
because let's go brandon crowd his butt
hurt about the word [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] them okay um let's see the
rock is trending what else we got the
holocaust is still trending
what was the one we were looking for
what were we gonna do i was gonna do a
diatribe here we're looking for one
let's see what's on the trendy trends
and the tweety tweets to see this has
changed neil young's still at number one
it looks like
um
has anyone has has there been any news
on this
um is has spotify released a statement
yet okay the rock is trending what the
hell is he trending for
uh oh it's just a new film okay
just making sure it's not you know these
celebrities they say this [ __ ] like
howard stern young you gotta make sure
this stuff isn't going on um
jim banks we did that i want to do the
laura ingram thing that's what i wanted
to do that's where that's where we're
going right that's what we want do you
say what you guys want you guys want the
laura ingram you guys want to see this
oh my god ingraham ingram ingraham
okay
let's um
let's let's let's get that thread going
here hang on a second let me let me get
it going here
i um this is
yeah my uh lisa says uh snl
and uh laura ingraham
lisa says she's so butthurt she's she is
buttered um over this um
she's trying to mock the person who's
mocking her which
again satire is [ __ ] dead with these
people they don't get it like they don't
even understand the parody that you're
parroting yourself like you are the
[ __ ] parody here jesus christ
well let's see
um this is
ingraham doesn't does an impression of
kate mckinnon doing an impression of her
oh this has got to be really [ __ ]
stupid let's watch this reason i like
kate mckinnon and i have so much respect
for her
is this is this her doing judge jeanine
or is it her doing kate mckinnon doing
her
because it really does sound like she
said box one i mean i'm not like i'm
only two seconds into this [ __ ]
and it already sounds like she's doing
judge jeanine you're alright a box wine
judger
she lost her show did you guys know that
judge jeanine lost her show now she's
going on the five so they're keeping her
at fox i mean they obviously have to
have her at fox who else is going to
bring in all the [ __ ] box wine for
everyone to drink in the goddamn in the
[ __ ] you know the the lounge right
the employees lounge
but you know they got to have someone
stock in the box wine but i'm thinking
that laura ingraham here has been
drinking some [ __ ] wine or she's
she's imitating
uh judge judging as a talent
she's so even-handed in their political
commentary but seriously like you you
can't hear the
the audio of kate mckinnon doing the
eminem bit up here on snl right
but she she does not appear to be trying
to be drunk
on you know as she's doing
laura ingraham here but laura ingraham
is pretending she's drunk or maybe she
is
think of all the low-hanging fruit
provided by joe biden and nancy pelosi
little pdb in the squad on a near daily
basis
i mean i think this is kind of comedy
gold don't you
reason what the [ __ ] mckinnon i have so
much respect for as these people really
do not [ __ ] have any clue what
[ __ ] satire or parody is look
when when someone does parody of you
you don't try to do a parody of the
parody of you like that's not parody
like she's [ __ ] with you
these people really have destroyed
destroyed parody and satire in this
country they [ __ ] destroyed it
because they are the [ __ ] parody and
satire it's getting ridiculous
they need to stop they're destroying
institutions in this country
death metal vikings said here that's
called a turf [ __ ]
oh my god
oh
how did i miss this one yesterday thank
you death metal viking oh my god
that's called a turf [ __ ]
oh man
let's see what what we got we got more
in here uh scary larry says that's laura
ingraham what laura ingraham doesn't
realize is kate mckinnon's impression of
her is much more likable
oh [ __ ] that's great
oh my gosh
okay um do we got joe we got joe here um
this is more like paul gozar doing kate
mckinnon
oh my gosh that's true
yeah all right
have you ever watched him chuck i don't
know i think he's got some neurological
thing like parkinson's or something
there's something going on with paul
gizer definitely his family says he's
[ __ ] whacked out too they're like you
know this guy this guy needs to be out
of congress now like right now
um
she's so [ __ ] up yeah she's she's
[ __ ] up all right [ __ ] up um yoda says
it's like watching don junior do an
impression and pers impression of alec
baldwin doing an impersonation of his
dad oh wait
he was just high as [ __ ] yeah the video
that we watched yesterday oh my god
the [ __ ] video of don junior is just
crazy ass [ __ ]
well um let's see
what else do we have here we have all
kinds of good art here but we don't have
a lot of time for that
um
oh here here's the actual here's the
actual um
impersonation
let's give mckinnon her dude now now i'm
gonna get dinged on this because this is
[ __ ]
dmca but we'll play this for a second
well we're finally done with year one of
biden's presidency and can we all admit
it's a disaster inflation's out of
control
gas is at 19 a gallon
okay i don't want to play too much i'm
gonna retweet this so we can go watch it
later
but dmca boy they're on top of this [ __ ]
lately cutting your [ __ ] videos
muting your [ __ ] because what happens is
they just mute the video like they just
mute that part of the video so you guys
don't get to watch it anyways on the
replay
uh chris says nobody likes you
chris inn uh nobody likes me
you're right you are correct no one
likes me that's why you show up every
day to comment to troll and i appreciate
you having here you're one of my
favorite hate washers chris in
and i love you for it i love you for it
buddy keep keep watching keep commenting
i appreciate it all right
let's go
oh let's go back to
laura ingraham
uh let's see and of course there's that
video
uh is there any other good good good
stuff here
40 43 minutes into the second hour here
what else did we do we have something
else that we wanted to get to i forgot
let's see
oh yeah chuck todd and rupert murdoch
why the [ __ ] are they trending what the
hell is going on over there let's see
what chuck todd's turning for because
he's a [ __ ] he's a stupid son of a
[ __ ] probably
um
maybe him and
douchey were
having it out
now let's see
see what was he turning for
um
here we'll just
we'll make this happen we'll get it over
here here we go
there we go
chuck todd thread see that
okay let's see what's going on
the time chucked oh oh oh okay so this
is this is the time patriot takes uh
opposed to this flashback trump once
called nbc chuck todd a son of a [ __ ]
yeah he is i mean he is i mean it's true
but you're gonna hate on him let's see
you ever see the story where i'm it's
1999.
i'm on meet the press yeah a show now
headed by sleepy eyes chuck todd
he's a sleeping son of a [ __ ] a
sleeping son of a [ __ ] well you know
what joe biden's little son of a [ __ ]
remark about
uh ducey was much better much more
poignant and the other thing too is he
really he leaned into the mic like he
didn't like fumble it or anything he
just you know made sure he really
punched that out there what a dumb son
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] right
leaned into the mic really got it okay
so that is that's the chuck todd thing
that's why he's trending because chuck
todd
um
is uh
had his son of a [ __ ] moment is that
why he was trending for the two seconds
is because he is a son of a [ __ ]
and trump called him a son of a [ __ ]
now here's the thing i'm not offended
i'm not offended the trump called
chucked out a son of a [ __ ] not
offended at all not even in the least
chuck todd is a son of a [ __ ] and
that's fine trump can call him a son of
a [ __ ] in front of a microphone if he
wants i'm cool with that i whatever
whatever you want the thing that you
don't get to do the thing you don't get
to do is be like oh biden's destroying
our country because he he called someone
in the press the son of a [ __ ]
and then you go back and you watch tape
of trump not only calling chuck todd a
son of a [ __ ] but all kinds of people
sons of [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
you people really are cry more would you
please cry [ __ ] more you weak [ __ ]
snowflakes get over your [ __ ] cells
this [ __ ]
um oh look at this [ __ ] no [ __ ] way
that's not happening
oh my god do she is trending did you
guys do that
i was calling him douchey this morning
i was calling him douchey
what the [ __ ] and you guys did you guys
make that trend tell us going on
midas lisa says i went broke on the last
legal af no moderators and no trolls oh
my god donated every time yes so um that
you guys do this thing in the super chat
and i hope to get the super chat soon go
subscribe to the channel
get your friends to subscribe as well
that way we can get the super chat
um
but you guys do this thing in super chat
where you donate to the trolls you guys
donate in the name of the trolls like oh
chris here he says
chris is real butt hurt that he has to
come here every day and hate watch me
i'm cool with that i'm cool with that
i'll even bring him i'll even bring his
comments into the show yeah come on
chris come watch
come watch every day we won't block you
as long as you don't say some [ __ ]
vile racist [ __ ] in the in the thread or
threaten people you can come watch you
can have your little comments um we'll
all play along we'll all play along with
you really you know loving the [ __ ] out
of me just coming and hate watching
we're cool with that we are cool with
that so let's get to super chat that way
um you guys can
[ __ ] with chris a little more okay let's
see here
um
i guess that's that's that's why do
she's trending i said douchey earlier
and now it's trending see how this works
i don't know that's probably not me but
you know i want to think it is you know
brush my shoulder off okay let's see
what was the one other thing that we
wanted oh rupert murdoch was trending
why was he trending
probably probably because he's a piece
of [ __ ]
um
let's see
let's see
i see why rupert's trending here
give me just a second just a second okay
here's the thread
okay here's the murdock here's the
murdoch
thread here let's see why he's trending
is there some news are they just ramming
on him
tucker carlson reader for putin to win
and biden to fail is rupert murdoch's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] dress blingy
oh
so it's back to the tucker carlson
loving putin thing is there some kind of
[ __ ] thing going on with that let's
see
um
tucko rosie is full of blooms and
russian state tv
multiple clicks to tucker carlson rants
oh [ __ ]
is full of bloom on russian state tv
multiple clips of tucker carlson's rants
are being used to cl
corroborate the pro-russian talking
points simultaneously attacking america
oh here's the story i think you were
talking about earlier kaelin
is the uh
when you were saying he he's um
he's larping for putin
um let's see here
greg has it here tucker carlson is a
propagandist for the emmys of our
democracy full stop and by allowing this
garbage on his net network so is rupert
murdoch hundred percent so now we now it
looks like we know why rupert murdoch is
is trending um
uh again they're they're basically using
all the [ __ ] propaganda that fox news
is perpetuating on not just tucker
carlson's show but their entire [ __ ]
network
uh to make sure to propagate the
pro-putin agenda across the world and
it's if you're pro-putin at this point
if you're pro-putin at this point your
anti-america and your anti-western
democracy that's what you are that's
what he wants to do he doesn't want
america to be a democracy he wants it to
be an autocracy that's what he wants
he [ __ ] wants it
uh let's see
um
see if there's news here
of course that's another [ __ ] story
here it is true that thousands of
american has needlessly died courtesy of
rupert's disgraceful anti-vaxx
campaigning on fox news
staggered the channel
is still available in australia
and the woolworths have supported it
with hundreds of ads over the summer
you know that
it it is it is a situation where their
propaganda is deadly um now rather they
can prove that they're entertainment or
news
and that's going to be the situation
here uh with some of these um possible
lawsuits that they have i'm sure
let's see
[Music]
yeah and the and the crazy part is about
the anti-vaxx propaganda just just
because it's profitable right it's a big
grift and it's profitable
um
you know that that's that's why that's
why they
it's so [ __ ] gross is because him and
all of his employees and he has a he
hasn't he has a vaccine mandate at his
company
like the [ __ ] news agency that he's
running fox news has a goddamn vaccine
mandate and they go on there and they're
protect perpetuating all this anti-back
stuff saying that
the vaccinations are bad and they're
evil and all this [ __ ] their
anti-democracy
no
no they're not
it's actually patriotic to get
vaccinated to protect you your community
the schools the churches
the people at the restaurant it's
patriotic to protect your fellow
americans and the data shows that it
works
not that it doesn't do stop stop reading
and aunt linda's [ __ ] facebook feed
that's not the truth that's all [ __ ]
she doesn't know what the [ __ ] she's
talking about the memes she's posting
are not [ __ ] true
stop it
uh we are 52
minutes into the second hour thanks for
joining me today here on the tony
michaels podcast this is the second this
is episode number 61 of the podcast but
this is the second day that we've done
two hours during the weekday of the tony
michaels podcast with the [ __ ] list
roundup
um
oh [ __ ] that's loud i need to change the
volume on that i apologize for that holy
[ __ ] you guys you guys probably all left
just because of that because of how loud
that was i gotta change the volume on
that maybe i won't push that button
anymore god damn but
thanks for joining me for the [ __ ] list
roundup i really do appreciate uh you
guys sticking around for the full two
hours today
come back tomorrow we'll be here every
weekday noon eastern 11 central youtube
twitter twitch
so we're on youtube now every day every
single day the other good news is after
we record i download the audio
and then i go post it on your favorite
uh your favorite directory so whether
that's apple spotify google a lot of you
get probably gonna leave spotify now
that neil young's like ah [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this so you'll go to different uh um
platforms but i'll still be on spotify i
gotta i i think i gotta beat joe rogan
back over there maybe give people a
different opportunity to listen to some
different [ __ ] than that [ __ ]
you know what i mean maybe he's got an
option to pick between me and it um it
picked me i don't know maybe maybe just
maybe go follow us on twitter
at tonymichaelspod and follow me and
gabe even though gabe didn't didn't make
it today and remember tomorrow i think
we're gonna have richard bitkoffer on
now for just a little bit she's gonna
talk about probably some election stuff
some messaging uh what we can do to make
sure that we win the midterms in 2022 to
save democracy because that's important
we have to stay pissed we have to go
[ __ ] vote and i don't just mean mark
the ballot i mean you got to do the
things that you have to do to get
engaged and involved not with just your
candidates with some other candidates
you got to find those candidates even
down ballot
so support support the candidates that
are up ballot in the federal election
the senate uh your your united states
congress person uh whoever the candidate
is for that race but also down ballot
your state legislators all the way down
to the [ __ ] dog catcher you need to
support pro-democracy candidates seek
these people out find them good way to
do it is just call your county party
just google it whatever county you're in
state you're in google that google
democratic party because there's only
one pro-democracy party right now in
this country only one only [ __ ] one
the rest of them want to be [ __ ]
fascist and they want to [ __ ] jerk
off the m m's having sexy shoes on or
some dumb [ __ ] i don't know they're real
upset that they can't [ __ ] have their
way with m ms anymore because they're
just not sexy enough i don't get it it
is what it is though what are you gonna
do these these [ __ ] nazis are gonna
nazi the fascists are gonna fascist
that's just what they're gonna do
so we have to be vigilant and we have to
know this but stay pissed go [ __ ]
vote because we have to have strategic
outrage and i know rachel tomorrow will
be talking about strategic outrage right
here on the tony michael's podcast so
come back tomorrow stay tuned tomorrow
we'll bring rachel in i think we're
going to bring her in in the beginning
and then we'll and then we'll go into
the [ __ ] list roundup after that
and we'll round up some some tweety
tweets and some trendy trends tomorrow i
don't know if gabe's gonna join us
tomorrow or not we'll have to see let's
see you know wednesday used to be
um our our our actual podcast day but
every day is our podcast day now every
single weekday is podcast day now right
here on the tony michaels podcast
youtube twitter twitch don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel so we
can get to that super chat that way we
can box out these these trolls
right we can box them out
so get your friends to come over and
subscribe uh all your friends on the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends get
them over here and getting subscribed
and get them to watch
and we'll keep going every single day
beat the drum
uh
also also if you don't mind
um this stuff does
does you know take a little bit so if
you get a chance you can go over the
tonymichaels.com
and you can check out there's the
podcast upgrade fun at the top and also
if you want some merch some [ __ ]
merch i know some people uh have bought
some [ __ ] hats here lately um and if
you want post some pictures on twitter
of your [ __ ] hats i'll i'll retweet
them and share them out so you guys can
everyone can see your new [ __ ] hat we
got red ones blue ones uh pink ones
trucker hats fitted hats we got all
kinds of [ __ ] hats we also have uh
stay pissed merch over there we got two
merch stores and it's kind of
complicated because some websites
integrate with them and some don't it's
it's a pain in the ass
but we got we got them over there go
check out both of them and then again uh
if you if you if you get uh if you get
funky check out the podcast upgrade fund
we really appreciate anything that you
can contribute over there it all goes to
the two hours every single day that we
do here live youtube twitter twitch
and i think i think um um on thursday i
believe on thursday we'll try to have
michael pop so stay tuned for that i'll
try to announce tomorrow if i can if i
can get if me and his schedules can can
join we also have a great guest this
week we're supposed to record the
interview this afternoon so we'll have
an interview for you sometime this week
probably thursday and then friday we got
bone end of the week
in the second hour
and if you want to watch last week's
bonehead of the week just just the bone
because a lot of people just like that
bonehead of the week show um we post it
on youtube um so go go over there look
for the bonehead of the week playlist
it's right on there last week's was
really good we actually talked about um
uh of course uh cinema was the bone end
of the week last week and uh i'll get
that poll up i'll get that pull up today
bonehead of the week we got plenty of
boneheads today so i'll get that pull up
so you guys can go vote it's at tony
michael's pod so go over there uh yeah
i'll retweet it you guys will see the
bonehead of the week poll and then
you'll vote on that uh today tomorrow on
thursday
and then friday we'll do bonehead of the
week in the afternoon
so what else we got here everyone's
saying fire
thumbs up
surfs up yeah we're going to surfs up we
surf today
um
all right anyway let's see
any other trends that we get
we're 58 minutes in the hour got two
minutes left everything looks oh sean
payton jumped up to the top now there's
some stuff going on there's some stuff
going on i'm gonna have to go over and
do some more surfing i'm gonna have to
go over and do some more surfing today
all right well until tomorrow at noon
eastern 11 central surf's up
[ __ ] surf stuff
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them